foreign
ladies and gentlemen it is 10 o'clock
like that
I would like to uh
sorry representative Maguire one sec
all right I would like to open the
public hearing on HB uh 266 and welcome
representative McGuire
uh
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol McGuire of Merrimack
District 27 and this bill was a request
of the administrative rulemaking
department and
I want to start out by saying it does
not authorize any remote or hybrid
meetings that are not otherwise
authorized in law
it simply says that if you are
authorized to hold such a meeting and
you choose to do so these are the
require these are things you have to do
to make sure that the public is properly
notified and pro and can participate
um there
the hybrid meetings are already allowed
if you have a physical Quorum in one in
one location and members may come in
um
in addition to the members who are in
the physical location remote meetings
are not currently authorized
in general but I know that some of them
have been happening and we this bill is
an attempt to make sure that the
um
that the rules are followed the public
is informed and that they can
participate and I won't try to answer
any questions no
this is essentially what was done under
the emergency rules in 20 and 21. uh
with a little polishing
as we learned what happened
thank you very much any questions
representative
thank you
um I just want to make sure that I
understand that what you're saying is
you're just clarifying what should be
happening
with remote meetings yes exactly it uh
it defines hybrid meeting it adds in
um
you know where what you have to do to
have a
remote or hybrid meeting that is
consistent with the right to know law
anybody else
seeing nobody thank you representative
that is the only card I have did anybody
else in the public want to speak to HB
seeing none I will close the public
hearing on 266. and we
are free until
10 45 so you have 40 minutes we'll see
you back here then
foreign
welcome back everyone it is 10 45 so I
am going to open the public hearing on
hb337fn relative to directing the office
of professional licensure and
certification to provide notice of
public meetings and an opportunity for
comment from the public and I would like
to welcome representative Merchant to
introduce the bill
good morning Mr chairman and also to
members of Edna
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
I represents Sullivan County district 6
which is Claremont and Croydon I come
before you today in support as a prime
sponsor
for house bill 337.
I won't read my testimony to you but I
will leave it with you
um
and respect of time
during
last year we passed Senate bill 330. and
Senate Bill 330 was created as a study
committee to explore oplc in ways we
could try to help the agency become more
efficient and things that they're
struggling with in order to overcome
some of the barriers
part of that process was to look at
communication and one of the things I
heard during the testimony over several
weeks from various boards was the
challenge
in trying to get notification of
meetings and the documents being shared
in the public session
so what this bill simply does is it
places a requirement in oplc
that the board a commission or a council
simply has to under 91a
notify
a meeting 14 days before the meeting but
also requires that any government
records
are made available to the public seven
days before the meeting
now I'll give you a little bit of
History I was underwater Pharmacy for
over 10 years 10 years actually
10 years a month and during that time
be on the board as a member of the board
I received all the documents because as
a board member you have to see them
before the meeting otherwise you won't
have time to reflect on them digest them
and so forth
I didn't realize to the public when I
was sitting on the board how difficult
it was for them
when I came off the board
I quickly realized how challenging it
was because the boards up there talking
about documents it's like we're doing
today and the Public's going what are
they talking about
and where's my ability to comment on
what's being passed so what this bill
simply does is put a requirement that
any agency or commission or counsel
or board under the lp PLC
um
meets the requirement
one of the things I noticed in
preparation for the meeting today
there's a drafting error I should have
caught it earlier I did not and why I
bring this to your attention is if you
look at the documents there's one
if you look at where
OLS place the document I should have
caught this and I didn't and I was what
caught my attention was why is oplc
asking for
a fiscal note of 330 311 000 it didn't
make sense
but then I went back and looked at where
the attorneys placed the bill in the RSA
and if you look at one where it's in the
bill now
it is in section 310 A1
I thought that was a11 it's A1 l
and if you look at a1l it deals with
hearings decisions and appeals
which was never the intent of what I
wanted to accomplish
when you get into a hearing a particular
disciplinary hearing the documents that
are shared with the board are relatively
private and are legally binding so
therefore to release those documents to
the public before the board meeting
would be problematic without having a
legal review
what I recommend to this committee and
I'd be more than glad to make the
amendment and give it to one of the
members on the committee as we move it
from 310 1
L to 310 1
a1d
d as in David
I think that's the more appropriate
place for the bill to reside it doesn't
and I would also talk to
executive director Lindsay Courtney to
work with her she has some concerns
about maybe some other things that may
have to be amended within the bill
to specifically exclude hearings and
disciplines because the bill doesn't
currently address that it only deals
with emergencies and deals with
non-public but this is probably
something that should be excluded as
well
so that's my testimony for you today and
why I'm here before you is to basically
I'm a strong believer that transparency
is important
that any government entity
should as much as possible
inform the public what they're deciding
and let them know what's going on
I believe in transparency I think we
have a right to know what a government's
doing I think the government has an
obligation to inform us of what they're
thinking of doing so that's the intent
of the bill
I'll take any questions
yes representative Brian thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Merchant for taking my question uh
starting with line 9 section eight
uh basically councils and commissions
can take public comment uh but what
isn't written down and should it be the
amount of time
allowed for public comment uh case in
point that I'm getting at in Nashua I'm
also on the board of alderman we give
the public three minutes and we hope
that they're concise and to the point
but that's uh a trait that not is not
really out there in everybody in public
speaking so I'm just wondering if the
concern I would hate to see a meeting
tied up for an extremely amount of time
wraps up O'Brien I totally concur I
think it's a good point I'd be more than
glad to incorporate that into an
amendment that I'll have either before
the committee or somebody on this
committee to introduce on my behalf do
you have recommendation to three minutes
um my concern has listened to what
you're saying is
is it three minutes per person or should
it be a block of time that the chair can
divvy amongst people because you could
have 20 people there
we're three minutes each which is an
hour so is it better to give up to 30
minutes to let the chair decide how to
allocate that time
if I make you may uh in the example of
Nashua everybody's entitled individually
to the three minutes if it takes
five hours unfortunately but that's what
the whole point of at least three
minutes is to try to avoid although we
strongly encourage if somebody else did
mention something you can get up and
reaffirm that you agree with that point
of view to expedite the matter but
you're again relying on the good nature
of people thank you
yes representative Lucas thank you
um
looking at uh at lines um at the part on
the public comment uh 12 to 14.
um unless I'm missing something it only
says to submit written comments I don't
see anything that would give people the
ability to testify in front of anything
is that am I missing something
right about that
representative said I think oh at the
section above it yes yes
ah okay thank you sorry and do you have
a preference on time allocation do you
think a three minute time allocation per
person is reasonable or should be some
other follow-up if I can answer them um
yeah I would go more with
I mean you might you might set a minimum
people can do but I I however you set
the rules I think the the chair needs
the ability to allow it to be extended
because you may have somebody with some
expertise that you really want to hear
what they have to say and it might take
more than three minutes rather than just
having a pile of people from the general
public commenting
thank you
yes representative O'Brien thank you um
and I'll ask you to form a question to
representative Merchant uh what you are
actually talking about is somebody from
the public getting up and making a
comment on what's going on what's being
presented on the agenda uh isn't so much
it is a difference between a public
comment and somebody somebody offering
testimony on the on a particular
procedure to which if somebody's
offering testimony then it is a widely
way that you want that information and
the time is given to that person for the
testimony is that the agreement
the testimony would not have a limit per
se that would be totally under the
control of the chair this is more to
allow people in the audience the public
to testify not testify but to speak on
behalf they share the concerns if you
will
before the board
yes representative Lucas actually on a
different topic and and maybe Lindsay be
better to answer this but it says there
shall be you know notif notice um
certain amount of time in advance
um so what happens if a board manages
not to give that notice does that mean
they they have to cancel the hearing and
until they do my understanding under 91a
a meeting is not appropriately noticed
you cannot have the meeting okay thank
you that's a 91a requirement
representative
thank you Mr chair uh representative
Merchant I'm
looking at the bill and it says that
your Amendment starts after Roman
numeral six
but the handout that you gave us ends at
Roman numeral five and I'm looking in my
tablet at this current statute that says
it was amended in for July of 2022 and
there's no Roman numeral six there
either is there something
are you referring to yeah representative
are you looking at 310 a colon 1
L Dash D D no I'm what I'm suggesting is
right now where it's
where it lies is in 310
a colon 1 L the L I took is a one and
that's where my confusion was and it
wasn't until this morning when I went
back and looked at my notes and I was
trying to understand why there'd be a
physical note of 311 thousand dollars
that's when I realized it's in the
hearing and discipline section and I
think we should move it from there into
the
other one which is three ten
um hyphen a colon 1 D in that section
so be added there at the bottom
may cut it may come I'll talk to the
attorneys down in OLS but I think it's
going to come down to adding at that
point in time where it says five
making this done a six and going through
it that way okay well that was my point
the the amendment I mean the bill is
worded incorrectly correct if you're
amending D yes it is that that was my
point thank you
thank you anyone else
thank you representative
the chair would like to call executive
director of oplc Lindsay Courtney
good morning
um Mr chair uh for the record my name is
Lindsey Courtney I'm the executive
director of The Office of professional
Ace insurance certification thank you to
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony today
um oplc does not take an official
position on this bill we certainly
support the intent of the bill which is
to promote public transparency
practically in the office we have done
what we can to promote transparency
since the state of emergency ended we've
continued to live stream our meetings to
provide greater access to members of the
public
most of our boards do allow opportunity
for comment for members of the public
that's considered best practice
and we we fully support the intent of
this bill to codify that we do have some
concerns with the way it's drafted and
we would be happy to collaborate and
work with representative Merchant to
address some of those concerns if
appropriate namely we just want to make
sure that there is some language that
allows boards to convene a quorum
if the need arises but doesn't actually
meet the requirements for an emergency
meeting I'll give you a prime example
right now we have a 24 hour require
environment for notice purposes under
91a
oftentimes we run into Workforce issues
members of the healthcare industry in
particular need to get licensed boards
occasionally still review applications
it's not uncommon for board to convene a
meeting on a couple of days notice for
example to review a licensure
application so that person can start
working we just want to make sure that
the 14-day requirement is not impeding
the state's ability to conduct business
and get work done as it's worded that
circumstance wouldn't be permitted we
would need to notice a meeting 14 days
in advance so that could be problematic
from a Workforce Workforce standpoint
the other concern I have practically is
that many of our boards that review
licensing applications do review them in
public session they are able to do that
provided you know the discussion would
not reasonably impact a person other
than a board member so when we have
these confidential documents that
they're discussing they're not revealing
confidential information but there's uh
personally identifiable information
there's accompanying documentation
transcripts
we would not obviously be able to
release all of the information on the
application and so it would require
extensive effort on our part to redact
all that information so that could slow
things down and I think
um you know there could be an alternate
solution you know maybe boards shouldn't
be reviewing applications in public
session
um but I I do want to bring that to the
committee's attention that practically
that that would be somewhat difficult
for us to implement
those are our
primary concerns and comments again
we're happy to work with representative
Merchant um if he so desires any sort of
changes and I'd be happy to take any
questions
yes representative likes thank you um I
can't speak for chair McGuire but I
suspect this would end up going to a
subcommittee that deals with licensing
um so you know
from behind the curtain she speaks
um so what I would suggest is that you
know you'll be involved in that and
maybe come with
um
some suggested language for things you'd
like to see to be considered especially
concerning um
you know I I want it's important to have
the meetings and to require that they be
held leaving too big a loophole to be
able to hold a meeting without the
notice is problematic so I don't know
where the line would be drawn on that
but you might have some ideas excellent
well do you representative
representative O'Brien uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you director for
taking my question I know in my job as
an alderman we have had situations
particularly when we discuss Personnel
issues and other events that we go into
a non-public and 91a does have a clause
in that that allows it to go in and then
we'll usually traditionally to protect
everybody involved make a decision to
seal the minutes and they shall stay
sealed until sometime at some point
the majority of the board determines
that to release it do you still do you
have that right
we do
um certain boards exercise it
differently certain boards are more
comfortable reviewing for example
licensing applications in public session
versus others review them all in
non-public I think an argument can be
made both ways if there's nothing on the
application that is problematic
it probably shouldn't be reviewed and
non-public because
um it may not meet that exemption
criteria under 91a I think it's five
so we certainly have that capability
it's just different boards exercise it
differently
foreign
yes representative Gerhard thank you
chairman
question for you when you're redacting
stuff how is the process done is it I
mean to me it seems like there's only
certain fields on a document that would
have personal information and it so
isn't just a magic marker and boom boom
boom done we all have Adobe Pro
um so we utilize an electronic method
for redaction some of our boards review
many many documents so it does require
some of our boards you know like
Foresters for example they may have 10
documents to review some of our boards
like Pharmacy they have a lot of
documents that need to be reviewed so it
depends on the board what the volume
would look like
but so follow up yes so a member of the
public could do a 91a request and get
these documents and they'd be redacted
at that point correct yep absolutely and
that does happen
yes representative
thank you Mr chair this may be another
question for
chair who
based on
sponsor's testimony uh it appears that
although this bill is marked as an early
Bill perhaps that's not really accurate
is that possible to be changed
I'm just wondering if there's enough
time to make the
corrections to the language if it has to
go to finance
or wherever
thank you yeah just for clarification on
that if that gets moved to section D
does that eliminate the fiscal note
reduce the fiscal note
I think it would reduce the difficult no
I think we would still have
um a need for staff support on we would
want to make sure that somebody's
reviewing all materials before they're
publicly posted
um we do presently have technologically
and we're exploring this the capability
of posting all public documentation
because we're using a different platform
I'm a little hesitant to roll it out
because with a click of a button you
could reveal information and we need to
make sure that we have internal controls
in place prior to doing that so
um we would it would make me feel more
comfortable if we had staff review
additional staff review prior to posting
information on the web okay
anyone else
you know thank you director appreciate
it
uh the chair would like to call Bill
Trombley
thank you chair good morning good
morning committee uh I my name is Bill
Trombley Jr I'm from Manchester New
Hampshire and I'm representing the
plumbers and fuel gas Fitters
Association of New Hampshire and we are
in favor of this bill and uh as I'm
listening to the testimony something
simple turns complicated I guess
the main thing is that we're looking for
is board meetings we're not looking for
emergency meetings we're not looking for
hearings or anything else like that
um some um you know I was the chairman
of the mechanical board for over 11 12
years and didn't see a problem because I
was at every meeting as I left the the
meeting uh the chair I uh a couple of
times drive up from Manchester which is
not that big of a travel but the meeting
is is not going on or it went on earlier
it went on yesterday
didn't happen it doesn't happen a lot
but it it it's happened and
um I think with posting the meeting 14
days ahead of time is something that is
really needed now
um our members and it's it's great that
these meetings are are remote and
um I have uh have now gone to listening
to the uh meetings by remote unless I'm
up in the up in this area
um the one thing that is um with those
uh meetings is that the information that
is going on in the meeting is not is not
readily available it's not posted yes
after the meeting I can I can ask for it
or maybe I should ask for it before
um our association isn't we're not
looking for the applications that you
know
um that the mechanical board I can only
speak for the mechanical board is they
they review the application and
non-public and I would assume that
that's a non-public document so that
wouldn't be
um available for for the public we're
just looking for the documents of the
business that's going on with the
mechanical board that's going on that's
non-controversial I guess if you want to
say at least get that have that have
that published
um just to address a couple of things
just one thing on the time
as far as time goes the mechanical board
is not like your committee we don't get
a lot of visitors so when we have a
visitor we kind of like to listen to
what they they they say at least that's
when I was there I don't know how it is
now
um so I I it would be nice to keep the
time let the chairman or the actually
the the board itself set board policy
set the board Rule and they in every
board because every board is different
you could make a board rule
um to limit the public test the public
comment not testimony public comment
that's one thing I would that I would
Rec that I would recommend because I
know with the mechanical board sometimes
when you get into technical it is longer
than three three minutes
um so I think that my opinion that
should be left to the discretion of the
board because every board is is
different so knowing about the meetings
um uh 14 days would greatly help our uh
Association
I thank you for your time
will you take questions I will yep
absolutely does anybody have a question
please sing none thank you so much
uh next up the chair will call Stephen
Rin Court
my name is the chairman and committee
members my name is Stephen Rancourt
um licensed electrician State of New
Hampshire I'm here representing the
electrical contractors Business
Association as well and we support this
bill for all the same reasons been
testified before you it's very important
we find it very hard as own business
owners is working to try to have just
two days notice to get to a meeting you
know I mean we're scheduled out months
sometimes and we do our best and it's
very hot as a general public to get
there and follow it online sometimes
because they only have to post it two
days ahead even though they may list the
entire Year's worth of meetings it's not
official until they post it so this is
very important I think uh we had a
concern with the fiscal impact but if
that's going to get corrected and
changed I think that we'll be all set
with that and we do have some warning
that we can offer if they do a
subcommittee meeting to help that I
think that could just be put on the
agenda that could be an agenda item that
states you know anything that made it
come in in the last couple of days we
have some warning we can suggest to fix
that having it in the law give them some
flexibility
but we we would like to see this move
forward and we appreciate the committee
considering it and pretty much
everything else has been said so I won't
tie up I'll keep my three minutes thank
you very much with questions any
questions yeah anybody
yes representative Gerhard thank you
chairman just curious what is some of
the things that you've missed at these
meetings that were
important that you know what I'm saying
like what are some of the things that
were discussed that that oh I missed
that you know seriously just they can
representative just knowing when the
meeting is like I've shown up here
multiple times and walked into the oplc
and they've told me that the
electrician's board meeting's been
canceled and moved and I drove up here
from Pelham it cost me three hours by
the time I come up and back and try to
go so it that's important and then
um the information I've asked for many
things that's been discussed at the
public meeting if I can get a copy of it
because I assume it's public information
if they're talking about it
and one time the lawyer had to walk out
of the room to go find out if it was
public or not they just talked about it
so I guess there's some confusion there
and hopefully they can fix that so that
makes it hard when they're talking about
test results for our testing for our
electricians and stuff like that or
information that the board's looking at
you know we received a letter from the
state of Massachusetts concerning some
reciprocity and we couldn't even look at
it but they're talking about it so that
public information posted on time is
helpful we can print it out bring it
with us
so it's very helpful all right thank you
and if I may miss a chair I also agree
that the time limit our chairman and our
board does a great job you know there
may be some situations or concerns or
items that are on the agenda that are
important and they require a little bit
of back and forth and information so I
wouldn't suggest limiting that time
limit unless it became an issue I think
the boards can handle it pretty well
thank you anyone else
single one thank you so much thank you
um that's the last card I have did any
other member of the public want to speak
to this bill
all right seeing no one uh
representative like yes yes we are going
to refer this to the subcommittee on
licensing and uh we'll look forward to
hearing from you guys uh with that I'll
close the public hearing on 377 uh 337
FM and uh we are in recess until 1pm
we'll see everyone then
mm-hmm
it's one o'clock I would like to open
the public hearing on House Bill 109
relative to occupational therapy
Practice Act and I would like to welcome
representative McGuire to introduce the
bill
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Carol McGuire representing
Merrimack 27 which is Allenstown
Dunbarton Epsom and Hooksett
and House Bill 109 was a request of the
occupational therapists to update the
language of their Practice Act
it is mostly clean up and updating I do
have an amendment which you should have
a copy of zero zero thirty H which adds
a couple of words that fell out
between line 20 and 21 between me and
the and OLS they were intended from the
beginning but as I said they fell out
the only significant change to the
current Practice Act
is on page two line 36.
where it says that occupational therapy
can be provided without a referral
subject to Regulatory and payer
requirements
this is something that's very important
in the schools because they frequently
have
people that
are evaluated by occupational therapists
but don't have primary physicians or
don't have insurance and the school is
is would like to be to avoid some of the
paperwork
other types of therapists physical
therapists and so forth don't require a
referral as long as your insurance
allows it and this is the same thing
other than that I will answer some minor
questions but I have people from the
profession here to give you the real
stuff
any questions yes representative Orion
uh thank you representative and uh thank
you representative McGuire
uh it does seem to clean it up but you
did say on page two
and uh I'm thinking about people like uh
within the special education type of
environment in in schools uh I think to
Paris and some of the teachers file
Medicare that doesn't affect that
because that comes back in reimbursement
to the municipality of the uh
jurisdiction that provides uh the
education it simply as I understand it
and they can give you more details
eliminates the necessity of getting a
physician or other medical practitioner
to refer someone to the occupational
therapist that the school has done the
analysis and said they need occupational
therapy
it may cut the physician's income a
little but you know noise level
anyone else
no further questions thank you so much
thank you very much
uh the chair would like to call Danielle
Amero
good afternoon thank you so much for
allowing me to speak and thank you
um representative McGuire for sponsoring
this bill my name is Danielle Amero I'm
the president of the New Hampshire
Occupational Therapy Association and
I've been working with a group of OTS
that have been trying to put this
language together for the past year and
a half so I'm obviously testifying in
support of in HB 109 representative
McGuire really kind of took all my
Salient points and already gave them to
you but
um occupational therapy is a diverse
profession that stores people across the
variety of healthcare education and
community-based settings so we do
believe that particularly that that
referral requirement does restrict
access
um just as a little definition often
we're asked if we help people find jobs
we do we do sometimes and it does
sometimes involve looking for paid
employment but it's much more than that
it's referring to all the things a
person needs in and wants to do in their
daily life as an occupation
so our job is to promote participation
and that can really be in
community-based settings working with
people with mental health issues working
with people that are not sheltered or
homeless so we have a lot of value and
benefit to the community and currently
that is restricted by that referral
requirement that is a highlight of it
further our Practice Act has not been
updated in 22 years and I've been a
practicing OT for 30 years so um
it's been a long time our occupational
therapy our National Association has
created a practice framework with
updated language that they've actually
updated four times sent in the last 20
years so what we did was really pull
from that national language and that
framework to just update some of the
definitions and Define our scope of
practice to make it a little easier for
the layperson to understand and really
support OT as a unique profession in all
those areas
the schools is a big important issue
because it's an administrative burden to
the schools to find the referrals for
the students under the Medicaid to
schools program this would be
eliminating that burden and would leave
us on a Level Playing Field with
physical therapy and speech therapy we
have worked with our oplc our New
Hampshire gov governing board for OT
throughout this process and they support
us and we have support from the New
Hampshire
education special Educators Association
um
we have also are working with the DHHS
on community on community mental health
clinics and the role OT might play
in those clinics and we all know that's
kind of a crisis right now I have
reached out to the other Allied Health
boards and their associations and let
them know that this was in the works and
offered them a copy of our Practice Act
I have not heard any objections from
those bodies
and I am more than happy to answer any
questions this does not change how we
are regulated by insurance we will still
have to get referrals for Medicare for
other insurance companies so that is
regulated at a federal level and doesn't
need to be regulated at the state level
the occupational therapists in the state
in their facilities will still have a
responsibility to their cons their
clients to make sure that services are
covered appropriately and referrals as
needed are gotten
um and that's I just want to thank you
very much for your consideration if
anybody has any questions thank you so
much questions from the committee yes
representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman uh just one simple question to
begin with
could you spell your last name I didn't
quite catch it absolutely and I do have
copies of of this the longer version of
everything I just said it's a-m-e-r-o
very good uh thank you very much so uh
and with regard to the amendment
representative McGuire has already said
that the language was intended to be
incorporated in the bill as filed but
somehow that it dropped out so you're
supportive of not only the bill as filed
but also as it would be amended if the
committee goes that way yes that it was
in the original language and
yeah very good thank you
anyone else
yes representative true
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I know what a
physical therapist does they make me cry
um what does an occupational therapist
do so an occupational therapist does a
lot of different things and hopefully
not make you cry something
um
it depends on the setting it really
depends my background is in the hospital
setting particularly in outpatient so my
specialty is hand therapy so working
with people with injuries to their upper
extremities but we do a lot more we use
occupation in that definition of your
self-care your leisure your work we use
those daily activities to help return
you to doing those daily activities so
say
if you were in the hospital and you had
a knee replacement and the physical
therapist is making you cry because
um they're bending your knee we would be
making sure that you had
um the tools and equipment so that you
could go home independently and get
yourself dressed and get your meals and
get and do those daily activities that
you have to do
any other questions
I have just one sure
um so this is obviously a repeal and
reenactment and you said that the
language has been changed to Define Your
Role better is it just a redefinition so
that people can understand it better or
is it an expansion because you said it's
22 years essentially since it was last
written has the definition or the
umbrella under what your work Falls
broadened I do not believe it's
broadened if you look at side by side
there may be more words involved trying
to capture what we do
um and and use the terminology but it's
the same scope of practice okay great
thank you so much appreciate your
testimony
that's the last card I had to any other
member of the public want to speak yes
director
I had a quick question so
um if you could just since this is being
recorded you have to sit at the table so
you're captured for posterity one way or
the other
um so
um so this is a redefinition uh but the
the profession has it changed
substantially in the 22 years
that you've been involved in the 30
years you said 30 years yeah hopefully I
look younger than that but I don't know
um so no the core of the profession has
definitely stayed the same there's been
a lot of advances in some of the science
research and it's really a terminology
update our terminology was
um very different when I went to school
in terms of describing how we do what we
do but we still do the same things that
we did if that makes sense all right
follow-up
so and and I believe you said in your
earlier testimony that you are are you
the chair of the board hey I'm the
president of nhota the president
Association and you the association also
endorses the bill absolutely yes very
good thank you
thank you again
director and Courtney
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Lindsey
Courtney executive director office of
professional Ace insurance certification
oplc doesn't take a position on the
substance of the bill
um but in reviewing the matter with some
of our advisory boards that are directly
related by the office they there was a
concern about potentially the language
being viewed as an expansion of the
scope and
um it kind of impinging on other
practice acts
um there is no exemption language in The
Practice Act currently so we would
suggest a potential modification just to
make it clear that for example
recreational therapists are not required
to be licensed under the occupational
therapy Practice Act to the extent that
their scope
overlaps other than that we don't have
any concerns with the bill regarding
that exemption language we see that in
other bills like the Medical Practice
Act if for example and we would just
suggest that that language be added to
make it clear
I'm happy to take any questions
yes representative likes yeah just uh
could you send us your suggested
language absolutely representative
anyone else
okay thank you for your time thank you
appreciate it
is there anyone else in the public that
would like to testify on Bill 109.
right well then I will close the public
hearing on 109 and we will come back at
1 30.
representative likes this is coming to
your subcommittee
[Laughter]
good afternoon welcome back I'm opening
the hearing for House Bill 258 and I
call the sponsor representative Kelly
I'm hoping I remember my own name here
I'm a little nervous
um I'm Diane Kelly I represent Hillsboro
District 32 which encompasses my town of
Temple and also Wilton and New Ipswich
and um I am going to be introducing a
radically amended version of HB 258
because the original version came back
from OLS pretty much 180 degrees
opposite of what I was hoping for so um
I believe everybody should have copies
of the new Amendment and this is
amendment
0051h correct
um I'm
I hope so
on the left under your name yes yes
thank you
um
so
um basically what I am hoping to
accomplish is to get animal Chiropractic
um out of the
um purview of the veterinary board New
Hampshire veterinary board and um
I hope that this bill will accomplish
that in the United States
human chiropractors are considered
primary care doctors so if that means
you don't need a referral to see them
but for Animals the laws are kind of
vague and chiropractors who are highly
trained and certified to work on animals
are at risk of losing their licenses if
they adjust an animal without direct
supervision of a vet and direct
supervision is a a problem that is
has come up in many states and will be
coming up in a lot of States because a
lot of animal chiropractors work on
horses or large animals and they're
traveling all the time you can't have a
vet follow you all over the state and
um the biggest problem that I see is
that
a lot of people who want their animals
treated either try to get a vet
appointment and it takes weeks to get
into a vet or and or the other thing is
the onerous expense going to see a vet
first
can be very expensive and vets tend to
be reticent to refer to chiropractors
which has been the case with human
doctors throughout time for a long time
human doctors were very opposed to
Chiropractic and that's changing but um
anyway it seems
um
rather sad that people would like to
take their dogs to get chiropractic care
and perhaps would not because they
couldn't get in for a long time or they
couldn't afford it or whatever and I
have known many people who
um just wouldn't do it they wouldn't
choose to spend the money or take the
time
whereas an animal Chiropractic visit can
be pretty immediate relief pretty
quickly and for considerably less
expense so that is my goal with this
bill
um and I think part of the problem with
the vet board is that there's a gross
misunderstanding of animal Chiropractic
and the idea is that you're not at War
animal chiropractors are not at war with
veterinarians it's it's something that
they could work very well on together
and um you know communication is
important but it's not like
chiropractors can't offer really
important needed care so
um I think that the best solution at
this point is to provide boundaries
between Veterinary and Chiropractic so
that people can get the care they need
for their animals and the last thing I
want to say about this is that it seems
rather odd in a society that doesn't
value animals as much as humans that you
can take your child to a chiropractor
with no medical referral but you need a
medical referral for your dog it just
seems unnecessary and
almost sad in many cases
representative Schmidt no
no
that's fine
anyone else anyone have a question
I'd like to ask what's the problem
you're trying to solve
um at the moment in New Hampshire the
veterinary board wants oversight of
animal Chiropractic and several
chiropractors animal chiropractors also
human but animal chiropractors have
received cease and desist letters and
they feel like they're kind of operating
underground which is unfortunate Montana
has a bill California is working on a
bill Colorado has a bill in Montana has
a bill I really really like and would
like to see happen in New Hampshire I
would love to see a bill in New
Hampshire muddled after the Montana bill
thank you but in in light of our
scheduling issues would your Amendment
solve the problem in the short term
I believe it would okay thank you
seeing no other questions thank you for
your testimony
and uh
Melissa ohala
sorry hello I'm Melissa orgilla I woke
up one morning and our dog Molly was
crying in pain limping and she had a
bladder problem it was instant
I heard through Diane Word of Mouth that
there's Chiropractic for dogs and I
booked an appointment
after two adjustments she was completely
good and I was really happy with the
treatment
I'm also a copywriter and I know that
it's a trending market right now with
holistic dog ideas
and I think it's probably a money issue
I think it's like mainstream doctors
maybe government it could be but I just
think that we deserve our god-given
rights for respect Civility and freedom
to choose our courses in our dog care
foreign
s why I think that
that I would be unwilling and unable
possibly to bring Molly to the
chiropractor could be because of money
because our last dog that we had we had
to put her down
we didn't have the money for the vet
and it's time sensitive if I had to go
through a veterinarian and I did have
the money
the um
I wanted as close as I could get to get
her care now I didn't want to wait she
was really in pain
and then when I was in the chiropractor
or the veterinarian's office last time
I like holistic medicine and holistic
foods and I asked a lot of questions
that had to do with what was in the food
and you know this is not related to it
but I don't think they had an
understanding at all but I was trying to
talk about
so that's another reason I just don't
think I think there's a disconnect
between the veterans and the
chiropractors I didn't even know myself
that there was such a thing as
chiropractor
for dogs until I met Diane and the story
and my husband's like hey Diane brings
her dog to bed is that crazy I mean to
the chiropractor I'm like
hey that sounds good I'll try it
that's what happened it's my story
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any committee questions from
the committee representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am chair I'm sorry I'm
trying to get make sure I get names
right because your testimony is valuable
uh could you just say or spell your name
so we have it correct Melissa or Jula
m-e-l-i your first name is unknown so
what is your last name oh July o j a l a
oh yeah
thank you
hey thank you any other representative a
bear
thank you for for your testimony Melissa
it's very impactful and I to share in
your view I've been there before so um I
think that chiropractors for Animals
just like people are a great idea and
thank you for taking the time to come
and and testify I know it feels very
vulnerable and a little bit scary but
you did a good job thank you thank you
representative O'Brien
okay you're good thank you
representative Earhart
thank you madam chair you might not know
this but I'm just curious had there been
any prosecutions of chiropractors for
fixing dogs or what do you call
adjusting dogs I think it's pretty new
it's a new practice I think so I haven't
heard of it I never heard of it myself
I'm just curious like are there
chiropractors in jail right now for
doing this underground I mean I don't
think so okay I'm just curious all right
thank you
another question all right thank you
very much for your testimony
and Angela Ferrara Ferrari
after things red light oh red is good
sorry good afternoon chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
taking the time to hear my testimony I
am here uh representing dog owners of
the Granite State we're a robust
membership of various types of dog
owners from breeders Hunters
veterinarians mushers livestock Guardian
dog owners pretty much the gamut of
things that can be done with dogs along
with your general pet owners I myself am
the President of dog owners of the
Granite State as well as many and
involved with many other breed
organizations in New Hampshire and
nationally
um my testimony is primarily focused on
the original bill that was submitted and
I would like to thank representative
Kelly for making the adjustments to
remove Romans 2 and 3 which deal with
the referrals required of chiropractors
from veterinarians
um our membership did not feel that that
was something that was necessary to be
put into law as you heard from the
others it would create some unintended
consequences increase costs for the pet
owners and drag out the time that they
would be able to get their dogs or other
pets into the chiropractor I personally
as a chiropractor for my dogs as well we
compete in confirmation which is if
you've seen Westminster on TV it's kind
of that form of competition but in order
to keep the dogs in good form and have
the best Movement we utilize
chiropractors prior to competitions
um and sometimes you need to get those
adjustments in last minute quickly you
don't realize that there's an issue that
needs to be addressed and have all of
this time to have that take place as
mentioned the vet industry is quite
burdened with the lack of veterinarians
they definitely have had a reduction in
the veterinarians making getting
appointments harder for the pet owners
and then in by adding the need for
everyone to use a chiropractor to need a
vet appointment to get that referral you
would actually be creating additional
burden on the vet industry not only that
taking away appointment slots from
animals who may need other treatment
that could actually be more time
sensitive for them than being slotted
after someone just trying to get a
referral for the chiropractor
um chair room and you asked a great
question it's one of the ones I have in
my testimony which I'll give copies of
and I did email as well but what is the
problem that we're trying to solve our
community isn't aware of any issues that
there have been with chiropractors in
New Hampshire nor anyone receiving cease
and desist letters recently as was
mentioned I would hope that we would be
able to hear from the New Hampshire
Veterinary Medical Association to speak
to that they would likely be aware if
there was anything going on that needs
to be resolved through legislation
um
going to the amended version that was
presented by representative Kelly and
Pauline Chiropractic from veterinary
medicine I don't know that we can have a
full position on that and that should
also lean on the nhvma for their
thoughts on if that's appropriate I do
know that chiropractors in general do go
through certification processes
to receive their licenses to be
chiropractors there's a couple different
businesses that do that at the national
level or within New Hampshire we do have
the office of professional licensure and
certification oplc and I think they
spoke at the prior hearing so hopefully
they're going to speak to this one as
well they do have a board of
Chiropractic examiners I don't know if
that Ventures into animal chiropractors
as well or if it's strictly human
the chiro Chiropractic profession is
regulated already in New Hampshire law
under RSA
316-a and the board administer the
board's administrative rules so you
could look to that let RSA to see if
that is encompassing and whether we
would actually need to create any
further certifications for animal
Chiropractic
and then
I think lastly I would just want to
request I personally and my membership
feel that the best option for this bill
is to vote in expedient to legislate
unless we find that there really is a
problem that is being solved and I would
take any questions thank you very much
are there any questions from the
committee
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair uh
so since the sponsor has basically
disavowed the language of the original
Bill
my guess is that the committee would
want to look at the amendment that the
sponsor really wants as opposed to the
language that she doesn't want
but so it does speak to
exempting
Chiropractic from
the
oversight of the veteran veterinarian
profession uh you mentioned the the that
the uh that there are New Hampshire
entities that do train
Chiropractic uh
animal chiropractors okay
um so they don't technically train it
but they would certify and keep licenses
up to date
as far as training that would be done at
a college or some schooling or another
organization I can't speak specifically
to New Hampshire organizations who are
teaching Chiropractic maybe one of our
universities but my understanding is the
old oplc for example is managing
certifications
okay thank you
okay
other questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
is there anyone else who would wish to
testify on House Bill 258 so chair
um if you're okay with it I'd like to
ask a question of Representative Kelly
if she's willing to answer it
representative Kelly
okay thank you um
so you mentioned that there's uh you
know
some legislation Montana that you
thought would be good and then you've
got this amendment my question is
in general what what would that
legislation may be for the future do
that your Amendment doesn't do and I
guess the underlying question is
is there a good reason for us to adopt
this amendment and pass the bill or to
just
uh for this year uh i t you know
recommend itl on the bill as a whole
you know what is the reason
the advantage of adopting this amendment
and then recommending the bill be passed
versus just italing the whole thing for
now if there's maybe some future thing
that might you think might be better
for me ideally the reason why we would
pass this as amended is because I think
there are people out there right now in
New Hampshire I know there are people
out there right now in New Hampshire who
would like to be able to utilize
chiropractors without their
chiropractors being nervous that their
licenses are at stake the one I use and
am very aware of would like to expand
her practice to a bigger place where a
lot of animal chiropractors use pools
like put horses in pools and underwater
treadmills and stuff like that and if
they're the one I know is afraid to
expand because she has been threatened
with cease and desist letters and um and
so I because my dog utilizes
Chiropractic all the time we were in a
car accident someone plowed into my car
and he's been injured so we utilize
Chiropractic all the time and I really
love his chiropractor and I don't want
that chiropractor to be afraid that
she's putting herself at risk
okay thank you
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so uh
there's been no testimony whatsoever uh
with regard to what uh I heard from uh
uh from a
New Hampshire citizen Diane Richardson
she's got a piece of one copy so we
should get some copies of the rest of
the committee can see this but I will
you know try to
synopsize what she had to say that that
uh
these animal chiropractors are doing
this uh yeah pass that down in the chair
with you uh are doing this but and and
they're clearly fulfilling a need
and
um and veterinarians are not available
you testify to that uh and so it's kind
of like going from here to uh Nashua by
way of um let's say Los Angeles
um especially in terms of the time
involved waiting to get a veterinarian
appointment so
Mrs Richardson told me that that's some
of the animal chiropractors are getting
some kind of cease and desist letters
from
veterinarians I think or maybe perhaps
the vet board and so forth so but we the
rest of us haven't had any testimony
about this issue so can you speak to
that so I'm not the only one that knows
about this
I haven't seen the letter from Ms
Richardson so I don't know what she said
but um
my own
animal chiropractor who is also a human
chiropractor hasn't has informed me I'm
sorry that um she has received I think
she said something like eight she
sentences letters over the years and is
she she's the only one I know of
personally who has received those
letters but I would very much like her
to continue to practice and continue to
see my dog as well as others
um so I I would
I'm sorry so I would like to have it
enshrined in I would like to have her
rights to practice enshrined in statute
so that so that I don't lose her and
Other Drugs benefits Ms Richardson did
send letters to the entire committee I
remember reading it okay and her concern
was largely with the as far as when I
read it was largely with the referrals
which are not in the amended version of
the bill
and so well my follow-up a question to
somebody is are these
um
animal chiropractors are they being
intimidated and being are they ceasing
and desisting as the letters are
demanding of them is their enforcement
does anybody know about this the ceasing
and desisting as far as I know they're
not they're not ceasing and desisting
for a lack of a better term but they are
concerned all the time I think it's kind
of kept quiet I would love to give my
chiropractor referrals but I'm I do it
by word of mouth but I wouldn't do it on
Yelp or something because I wouldn't
want her to get in trouble I I speaking
into a microphone you're being recorded
so uh
yes so
so you know from your personal
experience that at least some
chiropractors working on animals have
gotten cease and desist letters
recently from the veterinarian board I
don't know who has gotten what when no
no no one person one I do know of one
yes okay that's
that's and it's one I care about a lot
because she works on my dog and I want
my dog to be okay
yes representative Gould
thank you madam chair
I'm a little confused and trying to
understand this and I will say I receive
regular Chiropractic Care my former
chiropractor who I was with for over 25
years was previously the licensor of
chiropractors for the State under the
governor and
um and I know one time my rabbit was not
okay and I had to sneak him in after
hours
um to get an adjustment that was many
years ago I'm not up on what's Happening
Now my confusion with your bill
has to do specifically with
you want people to be able to not need a
veterinarian referral right but what is
the part about
um examination or certification I'm
confused on that part is is this bill
saying they will be uncertified
unlicensed
I'm a chiropractor and and anybody can
go to them no it would be animal
chiropractors would fall under 316a
which is that you have to be certified
and
um so so your intention is that human
chiropractors who treat humans could
also treat animals only if they're
certified to treat animals from an
approved accredited Chiropractic program
isn't that I think that's what's in 316.
well it doesn't say that it 316a doesn't
say certified for animals but right no
no I unders that's why I said do you
have a licensed chiropractor a few
humans and what do you want to do with a
with animals
this doesn't say they need specific
training or a certification or anything
my particular dog chiropractor does
treat humans but I don't think all
animal chiropractors do
I yes I would like all I think it's fine
for animal chiropractors to be certified
from accredited approved Chiropractic
schools if you don't say that yeah so I
should
include representative yeah I'm going to
look up 316a but
I if that's already there in 316a it
looks like the main thing she's doing is
saying that animal chiropractors are not
included under the practice of
veterinary medicine
but if they're already being required
certification under 316a which I don't
know that it is then they're already
covered by that but I'm not sure well
that's 316a but it wouldn't have to be
in per Bill if they're already there
that's but I don't believe it mentions
animals
so we have
we have Madam chair I I am I right to
assume that we have nobody from the
veterinarian board here to testify
I have no no card from anyone
uh we did get a letter an email today
from the secretary of the veterinarian
board saying
we oppose this bill with nothing else
have they seen the amendment
I cannot say as to what they have seen
or not seen okay Madam chair I just want
to does it make sense for us to uh ex
either extend this or delay this so that
we can we can hear from the veterinarian
board
that's one thing
um the other
okay any other questions for
representative Kelly
representative shewitt thank you madam
chair I'm not sure if this is
a question that the representative can
answer but
um since when I'm gathering she's
proposing these practitioners would be
under the same statute as human
chiropractors
have we heard from the human
chiropractors if they want this practice
included under their statute no we have
not that as far as I know
I have spoken to
one person who said the um who
represents human chiropractors who said
they don't object
that's faint praise all right thank you
other
I like to call Kurt Ehrenberg
good afternoon I'm Kurt Ehrenberg state
director for the Humane Society of the
United States and uh
the card says in support I'm we're in
support of the idea of removing
veterinarians
from the process of someone seeking
chiropractic care for their animal
and uh so if this amendment does that we
would support it if there needs to be
more thought put into the language or a
fix in another
part of a statute
we would support that most likely
um
and would be interested in following
what the committee does with this bill
generally speaking we're in support of
the spirit
of the amendment
thank you very much I appreciate that
clarification representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so Kurt
the the the problem as I see it is that
that these
some of the holistic chiropractors are
getting cease and desist orders which is
intimidating or inhibiting them from
doing what they are trained to do
uh want to do what uh the dog owners
animal owners want them to do
um and if we left them alone
um uh or if they were left alone and
we're not getting these letters
threatening letters
uh then we might not have to do anything
because it's it's going fine as I
understand it from people who are dog
owners Mrs Richardson
um representative Kelly herself
testified to this degree and also Ms
Ferrari
basically said
there's a solution to the problem of
animal owners who have pets that need
adjustments and you're saying that vets
are okay we're not tinkering that's not
what I'm saying he's the Humane Society
it's not the Humane Society so the
Humane Society of the United States is
who I represent I'm the state director
and and our position is we believe
animals should
be there should be Chiropractic Care
available to the animals
without a veterinarian uh in the middle
of that equation sorry I misunderstood
your reference thank you very much
Simon Thompson
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the LC DNA committee I'm Simon Thompson
I'm with Sheen Finney Capital group and
one of our clients is the New Hampshire
State Chiropractic Society I was not
intending to testify uh today
um as we uh are in we have a neutral
position on the bill and from what I can
see with this amendment that neutrality
would con the neutralness would continue
what our concern would be and where we
would probably oppose this bill is if
you were to open up RSA 316 and the
scope of the chiropractic care how this
bill's attempting to get what the
sponsor wants done we are like I said we
have no position
so thank you could you clarify what you
mean by open up 316a well we wouldn't
want to have we wouldn't want to have
316a at least
we want to have we want to have more
details on what on if you were to open
up RS to a316a and add Animal Care to uh
chiropractic care we would have to
reconsider our position yeah and I I'm
not comfortable right now to say what
that would be but that's what I was told
from the board of my group
thank you representative Schmidt thank
you so which Bill are you opposing
neither
didn't you just say you're opposed to
the bill no
no uh representative Schmidt I was we
were neutral on the original Bill and uh
as I read this amendment we are still
neutral on the amendment because you're
not you're not if you're not uh you're
you're going after the sponsors going
after RSA 332 which I believe is the
veterinarian statute
ah okay
thank you thank you other any
representative Simon thank you madam
chair um just looking at 316a it doesn't
seem to specify human either it just
talks about the procedures that
chiropractors deal with so would Animal
Care potentially fall under that
because it doesn't Define it one way or
the other
uh that's a good question I don't know
the answer to it and I apologize no and
that's why I'm Mike but I get what
you're saying yeah my main concern is if
you're concerned about it opening up to
Animal Care it may do that without
specifying
that we're opening it up to Animal Care
would you take a position on it then
if it's vague if it's vague yes I'd have
to check with my my client I apologize
like I got that's why I'm in a position
to answer that question because we were
I came here today kind of under the
guise of the underlying bill so okay I
just wanted to come up here because
there was some questions about you know
I think it was you representative what a
chiropractors think and although we do
not speak for every chiropractor only
the members in our association and there
is two two different Chiropractic
associations to confuse things further
thank you for that clarification
follow-up follow-up would you be able to
get us a statement on it relatively
quickly yeah that would be great yeah I
mean if if I may uh Madam chair this
this bill may go to a subcommittee or
well okay uh I'll do my best to get to
you I'll do my best representative Simon
to uh to uh get you a a position on that
as soon as possible thank you very much
appreciate it
other questions
all right thank you very much hey thank
you very much uh Jane Barlow Roy
uh good afternoon my name is Dr Jane
barlaroy I am the representative from
the New Hampshire Veterinary Medical
Association
um I highly follow on the heels of the
the previous testifier I was not
prepared to speak today
um I was kind of just going to be in the
background listening um and gaining
information
um to be truthful this is not really in
the scope of
the veterinary Association right now it
is not something that's been on our
radar this has not been something that
has brought up at the national level at
the American Veterinary Medical
Association so I'm really not sure to
speak to the seasoned assist letters um
from our connections to the board of
veterinary medicine
um we are not aware of those sort of
things happening in the most recent past
um
I'm sure you can get that information
from the board of veterinary medicine
but we are a separate entity the New
Hampshire VMA is a separate entity from
the board
um
I kind of wanted to answer a question
about this whole scope of practice and
where
Chiropractic fits into animal
Chiropractic as far as the American
Veterinary Medical Association is
concerned
um animal Chiropractic is practicing
veterinary medicine so not to muddy the
water any more than it already is it is
considered the American Veterinary
Medical Association does consider
Chiropractic adjustments on animals to
be practicing veterinary medicine
to the extent of what states actually
enforce that it is very wide very varied
numerous states have exemptions numerous
states do not even
monitor
um the the ongoings of animal
Chiropractics but in their policy
statement which if you would like a copy
of that I can I can surely get up for
you
um that is that is kind of the general
consensus
thank you very much that's
that's your position very good good to
know any other questions
yes representative Simon thank you madam
chair so from your perspective
um would you be able to articulate any
concern that you would have not
overseeing Chiropractic from a
Veterinary perspective
to be honest with you I don't know a lot
about chiropractic medicine
um I do know that there are aspects of
Veterinary Rehabilitation medicine that
do
have some manipulations
um I know that was brought up about
underwater treadmills and and that sort
of thing and that is regulated by the
practice of veterinary medicine we do
have board certified Rehabilitation
veterinarians that are out there that do
all of that sort of stuff
um
I think that it is something that is
polarizing in the veterinary community
and just like it is in the human medical
community so I can't really speak to to
that specifically okay thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you ma'am Sharon thank you very
much for coming up to speak with us uh
so I know that there are such things as
a large animal veterinarians uh and and
uh it's it's a kind of a very different
practice in many respects from dogs and
cats and so forth and the two people are
two the two entities are not the same
um but uh
a
horse for example I'm understanding that
horses needs these adjustments
themselves sometimes and I'm going like
I wouldn't want to try to do anything to
a horse that the horse didn't
specifically ask me to do uh because you
know yes large animals so the question
is uh and one of the things that we've
heard or at least I've heard from people
on the telephone is that
um they the current practices
the animal owner goes to the vet and
gets a referral to somebody who does
adjustments with a
certification of training so they're
qualified to do this is is that your
experience
in so I've been practicing for almost 17
years
um in 17 years I've never given a
referral for a chiropractic adjustment
um it is not something that comes to me
and clients don't ask me to do that we
do have a working relationship with the
rehabilitators which we don't have to
have a referral for that either we
we work differently than human medicine
if you want to go see a surgeon if you
want to see a dermatologist if you see
an ophthalmologist you can go on your
own accord you do not need to
necessarily referral from a veterinarian
do they prefer a referral yes they don't
really want people just walking off the
street and coming in
um however like I said chiropractic
medicine I've never asked been asked for
a referral I've been asked what my
opinion is and I've given that
um and
I've not been asked um I've you know
after the fact type of thing so but it's
it's not something that
um I have ever
given a referral for
eign
thank you can you confirm that there's a
school for Chiropractic
animal
it it's a specific school that's
different than people Chiropractic
this might be my own
um lack of knowledge but as far as I
know off the top of my head I don't
believe that there is a Veterinary
chiropractic school
um I can't speak to individual
veterinary colleges that offer a course
in it or you know A continuing education
component I do know that there is a
Veterinary acupuncture College down in
Florida so there are there are alternate
alternative medicine and alternative
therapy colleges I just don't know about
the Chiropractic part and I apologize
for not knowing that information thank
you
another questions
yes sir okay thank you
um
thank you for your testimony
thank you
okay yes
okay there is an animal
our clerk has identified an animal
Chiropractic College so there is such a
thing
there's also an American Chiropractic
Veterinary Association
okay does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 258
all right seeing none I will close the
hearing
and I
I think this should be going to some
committee sorry Tony
um
like us it will be going to your
licensing subcommittee
what's that
we
ought to at least talk about it before
we say we need more need something okay
thank you
all right
to subcommittee
yes
I have a procedural question is that
appropriate to ask now sure
uh when we send a bill to
um committee like this bill for instance
um do members who are not on that
committee have an opportunity to speak
to that with the committee yes any
member of the committee of can can
attend the meetings of the subcommittee
okay their public meetings okay and um
the more you know about it the better
thank you
and okay
a couple amendments no kidding I like
you
foreign
you know
there you go
um
Mr
good job
himself
like I said no that's okay
thank you
foreign
I'm opening the hearing on House Bill
409 and I call the spawn Prime sponsor
representative power
foreign
thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable committee members as the prime
sponsor I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce you to you today House Bill
409 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason and Greenville and
Hillsborough County District 36. for my
bill introduction I will address three
important questions about this bill what
why and how
first what does this bill do
House Bill 409 modifies the requirements
for non-resident licensure by the Board
of barbering cosmetology and Aesthetics
second why is this bill needed
the problem is
under current New Hampshire law licensed
barbers cosmetologists and estheticians
with out-of-state licenses who want to
work in our state are prohibited from
working in New Hampshire
in order for these licensed
professionals to legally work in our
state
they must first successfully navigate
additional requirements for New
Hampshire to recognize their current
valid professional licenses
clearly this is both unnecessary and
burdensome
in light of the fact that these licensed
professionals have successfully
completed their education
obtained the required training hours
have passed a professional licensing
exam have met all of the standards and
requirements of a State Licensing Board
and they possess the necessary
credentials to provide services to
clients this red tape hinders Beauty
Professionals in new to New Hampshire by
delaying their ability
to work and earn a living which in turn
hurts our economy
third how does this bill address the
problem this bill provides a simple
solution
first it amends current statute to
recognize current valid out-of-state
barbering cosmetology and aesthetic
licenses and second it repeals the vague
quote substantially equivalent unquote
language in current statute
referencing licensing requirements of
other states this repeal is practical
since requiring licensed professionals
to get additional educational hours
before they can legally work in our
state is an unnecessary barrier to
employment
these simple changes proposed by this
bill streamlines the current process not
only for professionals new to our state
but it also simplifies the process for
oplc and the Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics and
additionally it enables out-of-state
licensed Beauty professionals to more
easily become licensed in New Hampshire
without any unnecessary red tape
in conclusion this bill applies only to
licensed Beauty professionals holding a
current valid out-of-state license this
bill requires the Board of barbering
cosmetology and Aesthetics to recognize
these out-of-state licenses without
additional requirements
this bill enables already licensed
Beauty professionals to be able to work
in our state without the unnecessary red
tape and lastly this bill benefits
workers employers and consumers
by creating greater access to skilled
labor and Beauty services in the granite
state which boosts our economy this
concludes my bill introduction Madam
chair and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you
um
are there any questions from the
committee
representative Broda
thank you good morning good afternoon
um in last year I think it was we passed
a bill
that house bill 1560
that allowed non-residents applying for
a license
for the Board of barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics
they could have a New Hampshire license
if their license was from a state which
had substantially equivalent or higher
than those of New Hampshire
how does this bill differ from that
thank you for the question
representative
um this this bill here before you is a
refiling of house bill 1560. it passed
this committee with a recommendation of
ought to pass it went to the house floor
passed went to the Senate
and that's where it um
was voted interim study so therefore
this year I'm refiling the bill
follow up
so the I'm looking at your
so when you're saying you're refiling
the bill you want to strike
the fact that the board shall license
any applicant who is similarly licensed
and you want to strike the language that
the other states licensing requirements
are substantially equivalent or higher
than those of this state you want to
strike that language correct that is
correct and that's how the bill language
reads to to Omit that language because
it's unnecessary additional red tape for
a licensed professional who holds a
current valid license albeit from
another state last question follow up so
if someone has a license that has a
minimum requirement to mistake
that is quite different from ours
your bill would allow
that person to hold a New Hampshire
license correct
uh thank you for the question
representative
we are talking about individuals who
hold a
barbering cosmetology and aesthetic
license from another state and yes
States requirements to obtain a
professional license it does vary from
state to state and additionally I would
also add that many people
these professionals that come from other
states they have
work experience
so that is correct in New Hampshire the
required the required educational hours
are 1500.
the educational hours in other states
there that they do vary
and
for example in the state of Vermont
their required educational hours are one
thousand
and I have an expert witness who will
testify after me who can speak more
specifically to the numbers of hours
required in other states but it ranges
from a thousand
um some have there's only based on
current research
that was updated in November 2020 there
the states in our area there are seven
and their required hours
vary from one thousand to fifteen
hundred so yes some of them are similar
some of them have more educational hours
and I would also like to note
um last year when I introduced that this
bill that statistic was five states only
five states in the country so that's 50
states plus the District of Columbia had
less educational hours in the least were
a thousand
other data points having less were
twelve hundred
so um the the point I wanted to make
with regard to the updated data that was
um
in a published report by The Institute
of just Justice in November 2020 there
are now seven states that have less
hours and I would note and like I said
the expert with witness can speak more
to this
based on my
observation and Analysis of the data
that's because these states decreased
their required hours in order to get a
license if you understand the point that
I'm making
so
thank you are there any other questions
representative Simon
thank you madam chair thank you
representative power for taking my
question
um you mentioned that the
the state of Vermont requires a thousand
hours in order to get their
certification is that correct that is
correct from The Institute for justice
their um published report November 2020.
follow up yeah
um that being the case and then being a
neighbor to our state is there any
concern that if this bill is passed in
its present form that people will go to
the state of Vermont to get their
licensure instead of getting it in the
state of New Hampshire to undercut it by
500 hours and then just come back here
to work
thank you for the question
representative that's an interesting
question I suppose that you know
that that is a possibility but
um in my opinion is I don't see people
relocating to the state of Vermont in
order to obtain a license and and then
relocate because moving and relocating a
household that costs money so I I while
it's possible I I feel that it's
improbable to to be of any consequence
um
last one
um would there be any benefit to
consider just dropping New Hampshire's
requirements to the Thousand hours would
that be accomplishing essentially the
same thing
the question representative
um
that's an interesting question
um that that is not what the bill
um is before you I think it's a lot more
simpler and you know straightforward to
accomplish what I am trying to
accomplish through the language as
written that would be another bill for
another year thank you representative
Gerhart
thank you madam chair just a quick
question for you is State here defined
as also or does it also Encompass
territories would this Encompass
somebody being certified in Puerto Rico
or elsewhere
um could you say DC so DC is not a state
I'm just curious thank you no I
understand I was just simply site thank
you for the question representative I
was um simply stating
um
the data from from the report
so I can't answer that question because
I'm not a an
employment attorney so
um perhaps somebody else you could ask
the same question of another witness so
I would say that based on the fact that
it is contained in the report that it DC
would would be included
um as a state but then again I'm not
clear on the definitions
and if there is a question about that of
course oplc and the the board would be
scrutinizing that
I'm sorry that I can't give a better
answer
all right that's fine thank you
representative
representative power thank you for being
here today and thank you for such a
concise introduction to the bill I love
the what why and how my question to you
is do you have any metrics or any idea
on how many new licensures come in to
the state of New Hampshire from other
states currently today thank you thank
you for the question representative that
that that's that's a good question
that's interesting and in preparation
for this bill I did not
um obtain that that information and I
would be happy to do the research to
reach out to oplc and get that
information for you if that would be um
helpful
yes thank you it would be any other
questions representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh
I'm conflicted with regard to the
language that you're striking the
language you're not striking uh the line
two says any applicant who is similarly
licensed
uh what does that mean if you're
striking the
language in lines three and four
and what it was I'll ask you that first
what is similarly licensed in line two
mean if you strike the language defining
what similarly means in lines three and
four
thank you for the question
representative so similarly licensed in
implies that it's an individual who has
a barbering cosmetology an aesthetic
license that's
current and valid from another state
and they're seeking to get that
may I say to representative Schmidt it
means that if you have a manicurist
license for Massachusetts you get a
manicurist license in New Hampshire if
you have an esthetician license you get
an esthetician license
not you don't get okay the overall one
is is that correct for your attention
thank you madam chair chairman that's
that's what I was um driving at
follow-up then thank you okay so if you
strike the language in lines three and
four
um then you you got the uh the
requirement that they have the kind of
training that we have in this state so
how low can you go
thank you for the question
representative Could you um rephrase
that question uh it's I'm sure if you if
you take out the language in lines three
and four then uh
then you're opening the door to anyone
who has a license in any one of these
professions regardless of whether
they're training and and qualifications
are equivalent to what we have in this
state
do not
to what was that last part I couldn't do
you not do what I just said if you take
away the re the requirements in lines
three and four then you open the door to
anyone who has a license from any other
state
thank you for the question yes
representative that is the whole point
of of this bill that's in front of you
it's to
allow
the state of New Hampshire to recognize
a valid current license
from another state and the point being
is that these licensed professionals
in other states
they hold a license they've gone through
all the requirements they've gone
through education they've gone through
the training they've sat and they
they've passed a licensing exam they've
met all the standards and all the
requirements of a State Licensing body
and they all therefore they possess the
necessary credentials to legally work in
a state
um
to be clear heads of hair don't vary
from from state to state hair is hair
and if it's you know
if it's legal for someone to provide
Beauty services to to a client in state
a
it's reasonable to
permit that same
Beauty professional that is licensed to
to provide that same service
in the state of New Hampshire
yeah I'll remember that thank you
the representative Lucas thank you and
uh
which might help with that and also
answer my question is uh and maybe
someone else can answer it more
accurately but as far as you know what
is the lowest number of hours required
to get such a license in uh any state in
the United States
or DC for that matter thank you for the
question so
um based on my
cursory analysis here of this large
Report with many pages
I would answer that question based on
the data that I pulled that it's a
thousand hours
that being said there is a an expert
witness who is from The Institute for
justice who can confirm my answer
representative Fitzpatrick
thank you madam chair can you tell me in
this group
how many states
would be reciprocal to New Hampshire in
other words how many states would have
this similar courtesy to our licensees
thank you for the question
representative so if I might rephrase
your questions so that I make sure that
I understand it your question is you're
asking how many other states
in the United States have a similar bill
on the books is that correct I do not
know the answer to that I can find that
out if you would like
uh I would thank you okay and thank you
madam chair
other questions
thank you very much representative power
representative wrong
thank you very much Madam chair for the
record my name is Rosemarie wrong and
I'm a representative for Hillsboro 12
which is the town of Merrimack
I enthusiastically signed on as a
co-sponsor of this bill because I feel
that under the current legit the current
requirements is it's placing an undue
burden on uh workers who tend to be at
the low or medium income levels they're
they're coming into New Hampshire they
want to continue their profession and
yet we place these obstacles in front of
them that they cannot get a license
until they if they don't meet the same
requirements of original license holders
in New Hampshire we don't see that in
other professions for example in nursing
we accept licenses from out of state as
we're part of a compact with 30 other
states but we hold people
hair stylists Barbers to a much higher
standard than those that are in life and
death situations so I I believe that
that is discriminatory based on the
level of expertise and the type of job
and income someone's going to hold I
believe that if they have if they've
gone through licensing requirements
remember they have to hold a license in
another state I believe we should honor
that other State's standards of
Licensing
for as representative power mentioned in
New Hampshire we require 1500 hours of
training but many other states it's only
a thousand and there's no testing so for
other states so there's we may we don't
even test other you know people coming
in with an out of state to make sure
that they're working to our standards we
don't have stated standards for whatever
professional school they went to so it's
purely by hours so 15 hours in New
Hampshire
may be equivalent two thousand hours
training in another state I don't know
if it is true or not but that
possibility still exists exist
in fact and I hope someone from
licensing can can answer this question
but one of the things I noticed in doing
research is that there are several
professions where we might extend a
conditional license or we may allow
someone with a license from another
state to come into New Hampshire and
take our exam but we don't extend that
convenience to in the cosmetology
profession they would have to go through
that additional training in order to get
our license because of that lack of if
there's original license date does not
stand up to our reciproc
reciprocity requirements
so um I I be those are really my
concerns I feel that as representative
Powers said we need to do what's
possible to ensure that professionals
can come and work in New Hampshire make
an income pay taxes support our
communities without undue restrictions
and obstacles for them to do so I would
be happy to answer any questions you
have
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions
representative Schmidt
thank you we are focusing on the number
of hours involved uh but it's not merely
the number of hours it says
licensing requirements are substantially
equivalent to or higher than those of
this state it's not just the number of
hours that are involved
and that is the only reference that's
been made so I wonder when we strike the
language we're striking all the language
and all the implications of removing
those
presently statutory words
am I correct well my response would be
that in order for someone to get a
license at any other state there's going
to be somehow a minimum hours and
from the research I've done and I'm
sorry I don't have a list with me but
there's some states it's a thousand
hours some that's two thousand hours of
training of it's typically classroom
training so
but it doesn't get to the standards of
that classroom training someone may be
in a classroom for a thousand hours and
get a much higher level of preparation
for that for their position as somebody
maybe in 2000 hours someplace else but
it does allow us to recognize licenses
from other states and other states do
have license requirements
I hope that answered your question
representative Schmidt
it's an answer
okay
thank you representative
just a quick question slash comment this
seems to be this the hours seem to be
arbitrary anyway it works in blocks of
500. so a thousand fifteen hundred two
thousand it doesn't really I mean there
are bands of roving cosmetologists
causing problems do you know what I mean
is everything a problem here this seems
to be just some kind of bureaucratic
thing that was put in back in the day
somebody said a thousand somebody said
I'll do better you're you're so anyway I
got a question the question is thank you
for your statement
well if I could just address that I I
agree and that's why many times part of
the reciprocity agreements we have
require testing
um and and that is a way of leveling the
uh the expectation the minimum
expectation we would have of these
professionals but this isn't doesn't
have anything to do with testing
okay
thank you any other questions
all right thank you very much thank you
Russ Connolly
thank you madam chair it's great to be
back in house Edna I always love being
here a lot of new faces so
um for the record my name is Ross
Connolly I'm the deputy state director
for Americans for Prosperity here in New
Hampshire uh here to once again uh voice
our support for uh this proposal this
time as HB 409
um
as we've heard uh
this really is just recognizing another
State's licensure there's very little
difference where most of this uh the
folks that would come to New Hampshire
specifically to have their license
transferred to come and work here they
would mostly come from New England
states that's the the obvious thing uh
so uh the differences between the New
England states for for licensure for
cosmetology uh both Massachusetts and
Maine require a thousand hours to
acquire a license Vermont Connecticut
Rhode Island and New Hampshire all
require 1500 hours I'll require you to
actually attend a school uh and all the
other requirements that that New
Hampshire uh requires in in our license
this simply is is making New Hampshire
one it will free up Employers in the
state who you talk to any anyone who
owns a barber shop a Cosmetology shop
whether it's Super Cuts Great Clips or a
locally owned shop it isn't incredibly
difficult for them to find workers right
now last year this this legislation
easily passed the house I'm not sure why
it didn't become law uh there was there
was nobody opposed last year and in fact
I believe Supercuts was in support of of
the bill for that reason they are
struggling to find workers uh and this
is a a simple way to say we recognize
licenses from out of state there's very
little difference between those
requirements which results in very very
little risk to the consumer there's not
a higher risk to the consumer when they
get a haircut or have cosmetology
services in Massachusetts compared to to
New Hampshire there's no increased risk
based on that 500 hour difference in
training so uh
you know this is a service that nearly
everybody uh everybody uses it's a very
very important service we want to make
sure that these folks can can pursue
their passions as easily as possible and
as safely as possible and we believe
that this bill achieves that for New
Hampshire and and will improve the the
industry uh here in New Hampshire so for
those reasons we urge the the committee
to move ought to pass on HB 409
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
uh representative leckis this time
yeah thank you um
I noticed last year's Bill the Senate
Senator interim study do you happen to
know if they actually did study it and
if so did they report anything on it uh
thank you for the question
representative I do not
um often interim study is is a nice way
of uh killing a bell uh again I I am it
was a real mystery why why it didn't
pass uh there was very very little
opposition uh this is something the
industry was asking basically asking for
uh in order to free up their uh their
ability to hire workers okay thank you
thank you madam chair uh I'm generally
in support of this bill but my question
if if we if you know that uh it's back
to the bill sponsors too if you know
that it gets stuck in the Senate
for some reason
but I notice on your on the data sheet
that you have no senatorial co-sponsors
have you thought about maybe that would
be a tactic that would help you get it
through the Senate uh thank you for the
question representative I I know uh
representative power who who's a
fantastic representative my
representative Rose Marie rung uh both
worked really hard to to really get
support for this bill uh both last year
and this year
um you know I think the Senate uh is the
Senate they're they're busy with a lot
of their work not sure why uh
folks then sign on but I can tell you
that this this is a proposal that has
broad support across both parties uh and
again is something that that the
industry really needs to attract uh
workers here and and hopefully and
improve the lives of the folks that are
that are working in this industry good
luck with the Senate
yes that's always always a factor anyone
else
okay thank you very much Mr Connolly
thank you very much
Connor Norris
chair Maguire Vice chair Simon and all
distinguished members of the House
executive departments and administrative
committee thank you for allowing me to
testify on the regulation of beauty
services and Professionals in New
Hampshire I'm the assistant director of
the knee center for the study of
Occupational regulation at West Virginia
University
the main takeaways in my comments are
the following one is that New Hampshire
has a shortage of workers and should not
create arbitrary barriers for potential
new residents
two the research shows that occupational
licensing restricts Geographic Mobility
by seven percent
and three the recognition of
out-of-state licenses is an excellent
way to attract workers to the state
now New Hampshire isn't a strong
economic position and policy makers
should be commended for setting the
state up for prosperity
New Hampshire has a relatively strong
labor market compared to other states in
the country in November 2020 the
unemployment rate was below the national
average in the state
and the labor force participation rate
was above the national average
unfortunately Employers in New Hampshire
are having a difficult time finding
employers to fill the current job
openings
New Hampshire is one of the most severe
worker shortages in the nation with 49
available workers for every 100 job
openings in the state
so the inability of businesses to fill
these openings is holding back New
Hampshire
we estimate that 16 percent of workers
in New Hampshire require a license to
work now licensing is the most stringent
form of Professional Regulation
although they're passed to um and
designed to improve the quality of
services that consumers receive
they also forbid professionals from
working until they meet licensing
requirements so that means education
Hands-On training and passing exams
which can create barriers to entry into
a profession
and research estimates that these
barriers entry reduce the supply
professionals by up to 27 percent
importantly for this piece of
legislation is that licensing also
creates a barrier to entry for those
looking to move from one state to
another
because Licensing Laws are passed by
state legislatures moving to a new state
often entails reapplying for licensure
taking exams and sometimes even going
through training and education again
moving is already an expensive process
and this added cost can dissuade
professionals from moving entirely
we estimate the Licensing Laws reduce
Geographic Mobility by seven percent so
it does have a significant effect
now it doesn't only impact licensed
professionals and two income households
a professional who doesn't require a
license still May forego moving if their
spouse needs to go through a long
re-licensing process
now New Hampshire won't be going on a
limb if it unconditionally recognizes
Barber and cosmetology and aesthetic
licenses from other states
currently 17 other states
allow all professional
um regardless of the education level
whether it's specifically for Barber's
cosmetologists and estheticians or if
it's a universal recognition law that
allows all professionals to be able to
do that there are six other states that
require some amount of experience
typically one to two years of experience
of practice and then regardless of the
education level they'll accept the
license
again Six States have gone even further
and they accept licenses for all
licensed professionals so Arizona was
the first state to recognize
out-of-state licenses in 2019 and
they've already seen beneficial effects
estimated 6 000 more licensed
professionals moved in the state since
the passage of the reform
I can briefly touch on how New
Hampshire's education requirements
compare for Barbers I found four states
that have lower education requirements
than New Hampshire for cosmetologists I
found 10 states and 10 states as well
for estheticians
now given the difficulties of finding
available workers faced by New Hampshire
businesses forcing residents to complete
arbitrary hurdles to begin working as
especially costly allowing licensed
professionals to bring their licenses
with them increases worker Mobility
while still leaving those Consumer
Protections in place
this is no Silver Bullet to help
alleviate the hiring difficulties but
it's a common sense reform that can help
those looking to move to New Hampshire
with that I'd like to thank you for your
time and I'll be more than happy to
answer any questions you have
to representative
What other state has similar legislation
the ones that being proposed today
um I have a list here so Alabama
California Colorado Connecticut Delaware
Florida Georgia Hawaii
Idaho
and Kansas
Washington
I'm sorry I just need a number I don't
know oh I'm sorry I said how many 17
um either specifically Barbara's
cosmetologists and estheticians or all
licensed professions
and there's six more that require one to
two years of working experience
so 23 total I guess
thank you
other questions
represent Bailey
thank you madam
excuse me representative Bailey you're a
co-sponsor oh that's right I'm I'm sorry
all right all right
any other uh
questions
okay thank you very much do you have
written testimony
um I do yes thank you that'll be very
helpful
Drew Klein
uh thank you madam chairman and members
of the committee uh for the record I'm
Andrew Klein president of the Josiah
Bartlett Center for Public Policy we are
New Hampshire's free market Think Tank
and uh we are a 501c3 educational
organization so we do not take positions
on bills we are here to give our opinion
what the effects of such bills might be
and uh
I have some written testimony I can
leave for you uh so let me just start
with
the fact that occupational licensing
might not seem like an area that has
received a lot of you know scrutiny from
economists but in fact it has for
multiple decades it is a heavily
researched uh field of economic
activity and the overwhelming consensus
from a great deal of academic research
in this area
is that uh occupational licenses tend to
increase costs for consumers while
offering little and in some cases no
health or safety benefit
uh just as an example in 1990 the
Federal Trade Commission conducted a
review of Occupational Licensing in the
United States and concluded that quote
studies reviewed and evaluated by this
report indicate that licensing one may
not increase quality two has imposed
large costs on consumers and three may
be ineffective in lessening potential
overprescription of treatment problems
therefore the use of Licensing should be
limited to case Excuse Me cases in which
other less restrictive alternatives
are ineffective or more costly to
administer so in other words the Federal
Trade Commission says don't license
unless you absolutely have to and
there's no other less costly alternative
Stephen slavinski is one of the experts
who's studied this at the academic level
he's a researcher at Arizona State
University and he's specifically studied
licensed portability
and uh his conclusion is uh
that the general quote lack of license
portability has real world impacts it
keeps workers from moving to a state
when they might otherwise lack of
portability is also especially onerous
for trailing spouses of military members
who are often kept out of the workforce
when their family is transferred to a
new state
still quoting Professor slavinsky
getting a new license requires costly
time consuming and duplicative hours of
training just to do the job that the
worker was already doing before they
moved across the state border
as a result the lack of Occupational
licensing portability suppresses labor
market opportunities for new residents
of a state additionally it has the
effect of discouraging people from
moving to a new state at all now this is
a serious issue for New Hampshire which
is suffering from a years-long acute
labor shortage
last year New Hampshire was ranked the
third hardest state in the nation to
find workers the U.S Bureau of Labor
Statistics latest report
um
puts our total number of job openings in
New Hampshire at 50
000.
and this shortage applies to the
licensed occupation is covered in this
bill
the state has the State Employment
Security office has a single
occupational classification
classification for hairdressers hair
stylists and cosmetologists they're all
lumped into one classification in 2021
which is the last year the state has
released a report of this data
the total number of hairdressers hair
stylists and cosmetologists in New
Hampshire was 1860.
in 2017 the number was 2020.
so in four years we lost about 160
positions in this field while our
population continued to increase
we have a shortage
you might have experienced some
difficulty scheduling an appointment
with your Barber or hair stylist in the
last few years because of this labor
shortage
House Bill 409 would help to fill that
shortage by making it easier on the
margins for licensed Professionals in
these fields to move to New Hampshire
and begin working immediately
it would address this labor source and
portability Problem by removing from
state law the entirely unnecessary
Clause that grants Barber cosmetology
and Aesthetics license
reciprocity only when the practitioner's
home state
requirements are quote substantially
equivalent to or higher than New
Hampshire's
seemingly harmless claws but it's got
problems first it's vague what does it
mean
representative Schmidt we you were just
going back and forth with some witnesses
on uh
how do you measure whether it's
substantially similar
well one of the ways we measure that is
ours but some states require hours and
experience some states require hours or
experience
some states have one test to pass after
your hours some states have three tests
to pass some states have no test to pass
this is so vague that it's really
actually difficult to decide what
substantially equivalent to means
so we generally use hours as a proxy
for barbering New Hampshire has among
the lowest hours of education
requirements in the nation we require
800 hours of training
to become a barber only four states
require fewer hours than New Hampshire
one of them is New York
New York requires and we have an expert
here behind me who will correct me if I
get this number wrong the latest info I
have is a 291 clock hours of training to
be a barber in New York
now they have some other requirements in
there but if we're going by hours
there's a lower buy a lot
one could easily argue that this
requirement is not substantially similar
to New Hampshire's 800 hours versus 291
hours
but does anyone actually believe that
Manhattan Barbers oppose a danger to New
Yorkers
or that a licensed Barber who moves to
New York from New Hampshire or from New
York to New Hampshire is a danger to
Granite Staters
if you're qualified to cut Sarah
jakasuka Parker's hair I think you're
qualified to cut Maggie Hassan's hair
Vermont Florida and Oregon also mandate
fewer hours of arbitrating than New
Hampshire
for cosmetology
New Hampshire requires 1500 hours in
training eight states by my count
maybe more than that
um by a few but my last count was eight
states require fewer hours and that
includes Massachusetts and Vermont which
both require only a thousand hours of
training
I don't think anybody here would argue
that
cosmetologists in Boston are a danger to
bostonians
California New York New Jersey and
Florida also require fewer hours of
training for cosmetology than New
Hampshire does
again it would be absurd to argue that
cosmetologists in these states are a
danger or they should be forbidden from
working in New Hampshire without first
passing the New Hampshire licensing exam
so that gives you sort of the landscape
I'm happy to take any questions but I
think this bill by removing that vague
provision would not pose any health or
safety risk to anyone in New Hampshire
and it would not be a race to the bottom
because when you look at the actual hour
requirements New Hampshire is towards
the bottom for all of these fields we do
not require the most hours of training
Most states require as many hours or
more than New Hampshire for all of these
licenses so New Hampshire is already
kind of near the bottom so it's not like
we're all of a sudden going to collapse
to some low level of training or or
accept you know when we were testifying
on this bill a couple of Cycles ago
there were worries that maybe you know
Alabama or Arkansas or some State like
that would have
um you know no training or but in fact
it's a lot of Northeastern states and
western states that have lower hours
than New Hampshire a lot of the Southern
States in fact I think almost all the
southern states have higher hours of
training so
anyway
that gives you a sense where we are and
happy to answer questions
thank you madam chair
um I'm sympathetic to this bill I voted
for it the last time around
um so I don't want my questions to be
misconstrued but I'm curious about is I
feel like there are two elements of this
bill that are going on at the same time
there is the concern potentially that
this is a race to a bottom right it's
the race to the lowest common
denominator we're going to accept the
lowest standard available and that that
will increase risk to the
um citizens of the State of New
Hampshire
um by nature of it being the lowest
common denominator there's that side of
it or there's we're requiring too much
training in our state more training
that's necessary and should we also be
looking at lowing our regulations to
meet the surrounding states because from
testimony one of the things that I'm
concerned about is it seems like two
states that are directly abutting us
have lower standards than we do and once
again it's not just the ability to
practice in the state that I'm concerned
about but also receiving your licensure
um and so my question is
uh from your testimony it sounds like
you would say that maybe we're our bars
a little too high I I think that's a
fair assessment just based on what we've
looked at with training requirements
around the country
um again New Hampshire's bar is actually
relatively speaking low there are a lot
of states that have higher bars but
for the Northeast and for our neighbors
we're actually fairly High
unnecessarily high in some of these
respects I would say so I think you
could certainly make the argument that
New Hampshire
for cosmetology in particular were 50
higher than our neighbors I have not yet
encountered despite quite a bit of
research on this issue a really good
reason for that
um
but if you really want to get a um an
hours-long meeting then propose a bill
to cut those hours and you will see
you'll have a long long meeting ahead of
you
answer questions yeah I'd like to
mention that I know someone
who 40 plus years ago was living in
Massachusetts intending to move to New
Hampshire and while she was at school
got the additional hours because even
then
Massachusetts required fewer hours in
New Hampshire
yeah
and it's not the the customers in New
Hampshire are more demanding than the
customers in Massachusetts right
okay any other questions come up thank
you very much Mr Klein
uh Jessica poitrus
okay this is on you all can hear me okay
lovely
um dear chair chairwoman McGuire and
members of the executive departments and
administrations committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify in support of
House Bill 409 which would allow the New
Hampshire Board of barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics to recognize out-of-state
beauty industry professional licenses my
name is Jessica and I'm legislative
council at The Institute for justice The
Institute for justice is a national
nonprofit organization that advocates
for individual rights for nearly 30
years we have helped reform Licensing
Laws
licensing beauty industry laws in over
24 States through litigation and
legislative efforts we also published
the first of its kind report beauty
school debt and dropouts how State
cosmetology licensing fails aspiring
Beauty workers which details how
state-minded cosmetology programs are
roadblocks rather than Stepping Stones
first first firing entrepreneurs
all 50 states require cosmetologists
Barbers and estheticians to be licensed
each State's Beauty School curriculum
beauty Beauty practitioner skills and
techniques and Beauty services are
nearly identical despite those
similarities it is difficult to have an
out-of-state Beauty license recognized
here in New Hampshire New Hampshire
requires out-of-state Beauty license
license requirements to be substantially
equivalent to or higher than those of
New York's or New New Hampshire's
license my apologies
and to answer a question that was
proposed earlier the language related to
substantial equivalent to or higher than
the intention of that is to um is to
mean hours not to uh not to determine
other things like curriculum
um and and um
uh practitioner uh practitioner hours
outside of school
that arbitrary requirement restricts the
mobility of licenses which is a problem
for beauty professionals and employers
Employers in the state I encourage this
committee to support House Bill 409
because reducing licensing barriers
creates more opportunities for citizens
of New Hampshire
first licensing Mobility is exceedingly
important employers across the country
are experiencing labor shortages making
it easier for licensed Beauty
professionals to work by reducing
barriers will allow employers to have a
wider pool of potential applicants
second the substantial equivalent or
higher than language or requirement is
vague it creates a chilling effect for a
potential Beauty professionals who may
have an interest in working in New
Hampshire
qualified Beauty professionals may
choose not to bring their skills here
for fear of having to undergo additional
costly and time-consuming training
third this bill helps to empower women
most Beauty service professionals are
women and Beauty service skills are
easily transferable making this an
industry that is attractive for women
who want to continue to support their
families while moving from state to
state however the time it takes to
determine the quality of a beauty
license for these professionals means
that these women are out of work because
of needless bureaucracy which leaves
their careers to stagnate
this bill helps to get these women into
work sooner to support their families
and to continue to advocate for their
careers House Bill 409 makes a small
change to the law that will have large
impacts for beauty professionals
in conclusion I encourage this committee
to support House Bill 409 so that
skilled Beauty professionals can bring
their skills to New Hampshire thank you
for the opportunity to testify and I am
happy to answer any questions that you
only have
thank you are there any questions
well
all right I don't see any and thank you
for your testimony
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 409
yes director Lindsay
thank you again
um for the record Lindsay Courtney
executive director oplc uh the agency is
not taking a position on this bill we
generally support portability
um I think that there is an opportunity
to look at the hours requirements
however I think there is an unintended
consequence as a result of the Bill's
Language by striking the language
substantially equivalent to or higher
than those of the other state
the language currently requires that the
applicant hold a quote current and valid
license a current invalid license
includes licenses that are suspended
suspended licenses are both current and
they're both valid individuals with
suspended licenses on the basis of
discipline have to renew their license
otherwise they lapse or they expire and
they have to meet other requirements to
reinstate so
um because right now the statute
includes the substantially equivalent to
or higher than those in the other state
language
the board is in a position to be able to
deny licensure if for example the
individual has a license that's
suspended in another state if that
language were stricken
I would suggest that the language
current valid link license be modified
to use the traditional language which is
a license in good standing in another
jurisdiction I also wouldn't limit it to
State because uh you know DC is a
jurisdiction but not necessarily a state
I know that's a you know a legal issue
but it does create problems for us in
the office with that I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have
thank you that's a very reasonable uh
point that was probably overlooked any
other questions
seek done thank you very much
anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill 409
right seeing none thank you I'll close
the hearing and this will of course be
uh
taken over by our professional licensing
commit subcommittee
all right I think we'll be spending next
Friday on this stuff okay and uh we will
we will resume next Wednesday